there's so many Queen Easter eggs and
crucial details hidden in bohemian
rhapsody' that it's guaranteed to blow
your mind
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video and revealing all the
crazy little things even some hardcore
queen fans might have missed in the
movie and if you'd like more videos like
this on bow wrap and other musicals
check out my full playlist on the
channel freddie mercury's love of opera
and its influence on his work is well
known so it's fitting that the film
includes several references to this when
freddie proposes to marry for example in
the background we hear the most famous
aria from Puccini's madamebutterfly a
tragic tale of the doomed marriage
between an American officer and a young
japanese girl and the choice of this
particular opera foreshadows the
likewise ill-fated nature of Freddie
Mary's marriage later when Freddie rings
marry late at night we hear an aria from
another Puccini opera in the background
the version we hear is sung by operatic
soprano monserrate caballo with whom
Freddie famously recorded his 1988 album
Barcelona in a scene entirely made up
for the movie
Freddie more or less begs his former
bandmates to forgive him for breaking up
the band and asked them to play with him
again at Live Aid I need you and you
need me let's face it when I'm dad for
for raising Queens what's especially
interesting here is that Freddie's words
we're not bad for for aging Queens are
taken straight from the magic tour in
1986 when at Wembley Stadium just before
performing who wants to live forever
Freddie address rumors that the band
were going to split up telling the crowd
that they'd stay together until they
died we're not round for for edgy
and there's another intriguing detail
that some of you spotted in the scene
where Freddie pleads with Brian Roger
and John to reform the band after
Freddie steps outside Miami's office
while the others talk among themselves
he ends up standing right in front of a
gold record which forms a halo around
his head which along with his
conversation with Miami neatly
foreshadows his death there we arrived I
just need a bit of time but if I don't
have time on top of the four ageing
Queens line there's another hat tip to
the magic tour later during Freddie's
party when he descends the stairs
wearing a crown and full-length cloak at
the end of shows during the band's 1986
tour Freddie used to wear a custom-made
jewel covered
and a long red cloak while god save the
queen' played if you thought there was
something familiar about the embroidered
top freddy worth during his first
performance on stage with Brian and
Roger then you'd be right as we actually
saw that exact same tunic being worn by
Freddie's mum at the start of the film
appropriately enough just before Freddy
dons his mother's top we see him trying
on women's clothes in the store where
Mary works and as she applies makeup to
his face in the dressing room
she tells him that she loves his style
and thinks we should all take more risks
just before the band meet their
potential new manager John Reed for the
first time Brian comments on Freddy's
jackets they know his fancy dress dress
I've got to make an impression darling
you look like an angry lizard and that's
interesting for two reasons first of all
bandmate John Deacon is played by actor
Joe mazzello who's best known for his
role as Tim in the dinosaur-sized
blockbuster Jurassic Park and curiously
the term dinosaur comes from ancient
Greek words meaning terrible lizard but
that's not the only fascinating detail
about this particular moment in the film
as according to the costume designer in
real life that same white leather jacket
worn by Rami Malek in the film was found
in Jimi Hendrix's flat when he died
which makes its appearance in the movie
especially appropriate as Hendrix is one
of Freddy's favorite artists and an
enormous influence on him as you can see
from this photo of a young Freddie
posing as Hendrix in fact Hendrix also
gets an amusingly ironic shout out
during Mike Meyers cameo as fictional
EMI executive ray Foster who refuses to
release Bohemian Rhapsody Foster makes a
comparison between Freddie and Jimmy
after the band lobs a brick through
Foster's window you could take that
you'll never have a girl ditch comedians
Alec and to think I work with Hendrix
shoutout to Joey C for pointing out that
Freddy's robe appears to be emblazoned
with a dragon on the front and back
which could be a sly wink to the Queen
number dragon attack as the chorus for
that song includes the line gonna get me
on the track got a dragon on my back
this shot of Freddie reflected in a pair
of aviator sunglasses as he nervously
waits for his former bandmates to arrive
at Miami's office for a possible
reconciliation reminded me of the shot
of Freddie sunglasses on the back cover
of his nine
eighty-five solo album mr. bad guy
especially as a film veers from reality
by portraying Freddie as a sort of bad
guy for having broken up the band to
make a fortune with a solo deal as
Freddie sits at a bus stop scribbling on
a loose piece of paper we get a glimpse
of some lyrics from two different Queen
tracks first of all as a song seven
seeds of rye which featured on Queens
second album queen two in 1974 after
first appearing as an instrumental on
their self-titled debut album in 1973
seven seas of rye holds a special place
in queen history as it was the first
song they performed on the BBC's Top of
the Pops show as well as their first
entry in the UK charts and its success
convinced Freddie to dedicate himself
full-time to the band the second set of
lyrics we see on Freddie's paper a for a
song called liar which freddie wrote in
1970 and appeared on queens debut album
but those song lyrics aren't the only
cool little details in this scene
there's also an extra Easter egg which
he might have missed
when liya was released as a single in
1974 it's b-side was a track called
doing all right and you can hear that
very song playing in the background as
Freddie sits waiting for his bus we hear
doing alright again shortly later when
it's performed on stage by Bryan and
Rodgers earlier band smile the film
tells us Freddie first met his future
Queen bandmates that night after smiles
lead singer Tim staefel quit the group
though as you might expect for biopic
Bohemian Rhapsody plays rather fast and
loose with the facts more on that in my
other video what's interesting here
though is that former smile frontman Tim
staffel actually got back together with
Brian and Roger especially for the movie
to re-record doing all right the song he
co-wrote with Brian Freddie's version of
which appeared on queens debut album
thanks to the eagle-eyed people who told
me they spotted the t's made that
featured in Queens famous music video
for I want to break free which was a
parody of the British soap opera
Coronation Street the videos very
British bedside tea making machine which
basically combines a Ketel teapot an
alarm clock appears in this scene where
Freddie's lounging on his bed and
there's another classic Queen reference
in this scene in the form of the Bands
logo which you can see in Freddie
sketchbook originally the film was also
going to include a scene with Freddie
explaining how he came up with the
famous and the
which in addition to the letter Q a
crown and a Phoenix is made up of the
band members zodiac signs to lions for
Leos Roger and John a crab for Brian's
sign cancer and two fairies for
Freddie's Virgo however that scene ended
up being deleted by the way if you're
interested I've got a separate video on
all the movies deleted scenes and songs
several people also spotted Freddie
singing a couple of lines from the song
lazing on a Sunday afternoon from Queens
a Night at the Opera album as well as
giving Fox's opening fanfare a
distinctive queen touch Bry may also
lent two suitcases full of his original
clothes from the era to the movies
costume designer so several of the
outfits you see being worn in the film
are quite literally the genuine article
cheers to everyone who pointed out that
Brian Mays daughter Emily made a cameo
here and also that John deacons son Luke
had a cameo in this scene too in a
previous video I pointed out Bono's
cameo and dire straits music playing in
the live eight scenes while they're not
the only artists who get a shout out in
the film David Bowie in Elton John or
rather two actors made up to look like
them get a couple of sneaky cameos in
the movie the first time we see them as
at the start of the film though David's
face has hidden my camera and Elton's is
only seen as a reflection however we see
them both again very briefly at the end
of the film as Queen head towards the
Live Aid stage and right at the very
start of the film is just a few seconds
of real Live Aid footage playing in one
of the TV trucks where you see Princess
Diana Prince Charles Bob Geldof Elton
John George Michael as well as Brian May
and Roger Taylor current-day Brian May
also gets a cameo in the movie though is
in disguise and we don't see his face in
the final cut however if you look
carefully at the top of the pop sequence
this is Brian reading a British tabloid
and tons of you think Brian and Roger
Taylor also appeared on the live aid
stage sitting on the scaffold watching
the concert now it could be them but if
it is they're quite heavily disguised
what do you think let me know in the
comments there's even more cool Easter
eggs you may have missed in Bohemian
Rhapsody including secret references to
fat bottomed girls Wayne's World Marlena
Dietrich and an Adam Lambert cameo
tapleft to get all the details about
those four tap
my full beau rap playlist let me know
about your favorite moments in the movie
or any other little details that you
spotted if you enjoyed this a thumbs up
and a share are hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PK movie lovers